yeah because look some guys may welcome
having that thing that they can do for
four hours a day four days a week that
is other than just sitting around the
house if they are indeed complying with
the stay-at-home orders which is a
different issue altogether involving dak
prescott which we will delve into yet
again now and big cat as you mentioned
while i was providing the daily
disclaimer we're here to provide a
distraction from the pandemic there is
overlap between the pandemic and
football and there is a significant
chunk of overlap as it relates to dak
prescott in the dallas cowboys because
prescott broke his silence on tuesday
four days after he reportedly hosted a
party this was a tmz report that had
photographic evidence of food that
looked like it was intended for more
than a few people uh and also people who
were maybe clustered a little more
closely together than they should be and
there were some other allegations made
of up to 30 people at dak prescott's
home for a birthday party for a friend
dak prescott came out and issued a
statement it was sent to us and others i
understand and accept that there are
additional responsibilities and media
scrutiny that come with being an nfl
quarterback but it is very frustrating
and disappointing when people provide
completely inaccurate information from
anonymous sources especially now to set
the record straight i know that we all
need to do our best to socially distance
and like everyone else i am continuing
to adjust to what that requires but the
truth is that i was with fewer than 10
people for a home dinner not a party on
friday night that's dak prescott's
statement uh you can see it at
profootballtalk.com and react to it
there and look i
this messes with what someone close to
him said in the aftermath of the tmz
report of a party of up to 30. there
were fewer than 10 and social distancing
was complied with at all times but there
is a different issue here big cat and i
think it's important for people to
understand this
if the people at his house weren't
people who live with him at his house
he was providing a way for people to
violate the stay-at-home order in texas
by leaving their homes and coming to his
house and that's not a technicality
right everybody should be staying home
while we keep the spread of the virus
under control and if you're having a
dinner or a party or whatever the hell
label you're going to apply to it and
you're having people leave their homes
in violation of the stay-at-home order
and come to your house that's a problem
and when there are millions of people
who are complying with these
requirements in order to limit the
spread of the virus protect family
members and strangers and anyone who it
could make incredibly sick or kill
it is a little bit glaring when the
quarterback of america's team isn't
complying with it and it's amazing to me
how many people violently disagree with
that to the point where i wonder whether
people really are listening to the dr
fouches of the world really do get it
and understand what need to be done or
are they just so frustrated by the
situation they're going to blow off
steam even though they ultimately do
comply they want to yell and scream at
anyone who reminds them of this
existence we're now all trapped in
well i think it's hard for people to
fully grasp what's going on so i'm not
surprised that you've had a negative uh
interaction with people online who
basically say florio you're being a
stick in the mud i to me
it's more you know let's just say dak
prescott had eight people and you're
right like letting other people into
your bubble then compromises people
outside your bubble it's pretty clear
what they've told us about this disease
and what you're supposed to do and what
you're not supposed to do and he did
exactly what you're not supposed to do
let's just throw all that out
to side for a second it's
actually to me a simple judgment thing
where dak prescott like you like read
the room that that's more my issue if
i'm if i'm you know stephen jones or
jerry jones it's simply like hey you're
supposed to be the quarterback of the
dallas cowboys read the room figure out
what's going on in the world and don't
be the guy who screws up and has
everyone yell at him we had that weekend
back in like mid-march i think it was
right around st patrick's day where the
the nation kind of you know flipped and
realized what was going on and there was
that weekend where everyone was getting
shamed for going out and i think a lot
of people went out that weekend not
realizing the severity of this and they
almost not get a pass they do get a pass
because they didn't fully understand it
but if we're three four weeks five weeks
into you know here in new york city
where i think this start of week five
basically being trapped in our homes and
you're doing a party like this that just
is such a glaring
you know lack of of understanding what's
going on around you and that's more
concerning in a weird way if you're the
cowboys than breaking the cdc guidelines
which is clearly more concerning in a
big you know global issue here but if
you're the cowboys you're like deck what
are you doing here man like figure it
out like even
even if you want to do it and and have
no cell phones like we'll never know you
shouldn't do it but at least we won't
know the fact that he had cell phones
there people were taking pictures i
agree with you there's a lot of food
more than it there should be for 10
people but in one defense of dak
prescott i'm an over order when it comes
to parties and i like to have leftovers
so maybe that was what he was going for
and this
party this dinner or whatever we want to
call it it came in the aftermath of two
different situations where dak prescott
and dez bryant were working out outside
of their homes at facilities that should
have been closed based upon local and
state orders for staying at home and
shutting down non-essential businesses
and the first time they worked out it
was capped with a photo of five guys
draped arm and arm which clearly was
tone deaf to social distancing and
stay-at-home orders and then they did it
again and the evidence kept showing up
on social media because dez bryant is
more interested in getting a job than he
is in complying with the stay-at-home
orders and dak was caught in the middle
of that so if you weren't already
sensitive to the issues before the two
different occasions when you left your
home to work out with dez bryant and got
called out for it
well that makes it even more glaring
that you have people come over to your
house and have a dinner or a party when
everyone should be staying at home and i
i'm with you like at what point
is it not an excuse to be oblivious this
is the one thing that has affected all
of us in a very profound way even if you
don't watch the news at some point
this issue is going to land right in the
middle of your radar screen and natural
human curiosity is going to get you to
try to figure out exactly what this is
all about and what's expected of me and
it's not all that hard to figure out
what's expected of you and it's not all
that hard to comply with what's expected
of you stay at home and don't have
anyone come over to your house because
they're all supposed to stay at home as
well and i agree with you from the
cowboys perspective
it's not like they're rescinding the
franchise tender and they don't want him
to be their quarterback but at some
level you got to have people in that
organization thinking
what the hell is wrong here
yeah no i listen i agree and and you're
spot on but i also
you know i remember being how old is dak
prescott 22 25 26 27 i mean how old is
he somewhere in that time frame mid-20s
yeah right mid-20s i remember being in
my mid-20s i remember thinking that i
had figured out you know all of life i
remember thinking that i was invincible
especially if you're a pro athlete who
is kind of invincible you know
health-wise in a lot of ways so
it's hard for me
as stupid as this was and he should be
criticized because guess what being
criticized in this moment will actually
probably help spread awareness to more
people but i will also step back at the
end of the day and be like hey i know
dak prescott is probably thinking to
himself there's no chance that this
thing will affect me in any way and i
can't blame him because we all at one
point in time were walking around with
that you know 25 mid 20s confidence that
we were invincible and that nothing
could stop us so i know what that felt
like and i'm not going to sit here and
be old man yells a cloud like you florio
and now let's give him not at least give
him that decency where it's like i've
been in that spot and i would be foolish
to tell you that i was you know wise and
mature when i was in my mid-20s to be
able to listen to these things
two quick points number one this isn't
doing something stupid that just
endangers you like riding around on a
motorcycle without a helmet it endangers
other people and i think that's enough
to bust through that sense of
invincibility you have when you're a
professional athlete in your mid-20s
early 20s whatever the case may be and
number two
the fact that there have been so many
voices early in this process who
for reasons that still aren't entirely
clear although i think some of them were
doing it simply to cater to their main
audience and for profit the people who
were spreading bs the people who were
grabbing the microphone and saying this
is just the flu this is no big deal go
about your lives when i'm in my early
20s and i want to go about my life i
grab onto that message that's the danger
of that message that people in the media
were spreading and they know who they
are that when you spread that you
empower people who are looking for any
excuse they can to live their lives the
way they want to live their lives and
they are glad that you're saying that
because it gives them the license to do
the thing that deep down they know they
maybe shouldn't do and deep down i think
dak knows he shouldn't have done it deep
down stephen jones knows he shouldn't
have done it because he said yesterday
on 105.3 the fan we've certainly
communicated with dak and zeke ezekiel
elliott was also at the dinner or the
party or whatever it was i think they're
certainly aware now of how sensitive
these situations are and i don't think
you'll be seeing that any more that was
the word from
stephen jones son of team owner jerry
jones
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports